how much time do I have months that
passed I still have a lot of work that
needs to be done
it was our desire to make a film it
feels more like the early Saw movies
this in in our mind is really sought to
this movie happens weeks after the end
of saw one I help people overcome inner
obstacles
it needed to look like the early summer
they were shot on 35 they were scuzzy
and gritty they're you know there's our
cynical greens and ocher yellows we're
working with a cinematographer here who
has just done a fabulous job
one of the great challenges of this
project was really putting together an
excellent trap team and I feel like we
have this amazing team
and I think that the fans are going to
be happy
all the people that really love saw I
want to play a game my job
is to bring Humanity to John Kramer
the traps I leave to the people who are
Disturbed enough to come to come up with
some of these things and we go back to
what I think the audience most enjoys
about John Kramer's character a wage war
a wage war against mediocrity what
struck me was the relationship between
John and Amanda I think that's some of
the best passages or scenes everyone
deserves a chance you should know that
more than anyone it's super
fun to be able to come all the way back
to the beginning
we really did this movie for the fans
the story is compelling and the saw fans
Next Level we really tried to pay them
back for the loyalty and the fans that
have been there since so one and that's
why there's the Easter eggs there's
Throwbacks we just really tried to say
you've asked for this movie We're making
this for you
[Music]